What's in a logo?
When the Gap went for a radical redesign of their classic logo,...
...the backlash was fast and furious.
When you're thinking about a logo for your business,...
...follow these basic guidelines to make sure you're headed in the right direction.
Go for classic instead of trendy,...
...because constantly changing your logo won't do any favors for your branding.
Stick with clean and streamlined.
Focus on a key image and company name.
Keep in mind that your logo has to translate in lots of different sizes,...
...from a product label to a billboard.
Choose your colors carefully...
...and make sure they jive with everything from your website to product packaging.
Don't be afraid to nitpick over details...
...or go back to the drawing board if you just aren't feeling it.